- [Auto-Attendant] All
of our representatives
are currently busy.
Please stay on the line
and your call will be answered
by the next available representative.
Today's customer hates
to wait for service.
When I call up a brand
or a service provider,
I expect to get my
questions answered quickly
and to my satisfaction.
In the world of customer service,
the challenge is to stay a step ahead
of customer expectations
and ensure that every brand interaction
is not just positive, but
delightful for the customer.
My name is Manish Goyal
and I'm a Senior Partner
in IBM Consulting,
leading our AI analytics
business globally.
The goal of my team is to help our clients
apply AI analytics and
automation to create insights
that drive better decisions.
And one of the areas I
spend a lot of time in
is advising clients on how
AI analytics can help deliver
delightful customer experiences.
This could be through
self-service experiences
or through aiding human agents
with tools and insights
so that they can deliver
a great experience to the customer.
Now, enterprises spend billions of dollars
on customer service every year.
Good customer service
can turn one-time clients into
long-term brand champions.
And the lifetime value of an NPS promoter
can be 10 times more
than an NPS detractor.
On the other hand, around
80% of consumers say
they would rather do
business with a competitor
after more than one bad
experience with a brand.
The contact center,
the hub of most customer
service operations,
has come a long way in the
past couple of decades.
Tools such as interactive
voice response (IVR),
agent assist, robotic process
automation and chat bots
have already made customer
service agents more productive.
However, at most enterprises,
the use of these technologies
is fragmented instead of seamless.
At the same time,
customer expectations continue
to be more and more demanding
these days, especially
coming out of the pandemic.
Customers expect seamless
access and speedy resolution
to their queries across
digital and voice channels.
This in turn puts pressure on businesses
to deliver a frictionless
customer experience
at every stage, from
discovery to purchase,
through service and retention.
Now with generative AI,
this experience can be
taken to the next level.
Large language models have the
power to significantly expand
what can be automated,
performing critical customer service tasks
that are far beyond the capacities
of earlier technologies.
These models are trained
on vast amounts of data
and can recognize, classify, and create
sophisticated text and speech
with speed and precision.
To see how
generative AI can significantly
improve customer service,
let's look at three key areas.
The first is self-service,
wherein you give the tools to
customers to serve themselves.
Virtual agents or chatbots
serve the purpose here.
And over the years, they
have become very good
at being able to direct customers
down a predetermined journey.
To make these journeys,
you first analyze what
people are asking about,
you understand their intent
and then handcraft the dialogue flows
to direct them down the right journeys.
In the past, creating
these flows took time,
but now with generative AI,
you can deliver much richer
self-service experiences.
These experiences are more
natural and conversational.
They're more resilient to
variations and digressions,
and the tooling to create these flows
is also now being augmented
with generative AI,
so that the process area
and domain area experts
can describe the journeys
in natural language
and AI generates the
necessary underlying flows.
The second area,
where generative AI can
significantly improve
customer experience is by
augmenting the human agent,
whether in the contact
center or in the field.
A lot of time is spent by
agents in the contact center
searching knowledge bases
to resolve the queries for customers.
Generative AI can dramatically
improve the retrieval
of this information
from the knowledge bases
and present it back to
agents in a summarized way,
to help resolve the
customer query quickly.
This cuts down the time that
the customer is on hold,
improving their experience,
while also allowing the
agent to handle more calls
during their shift.
Similarly, field service
agents can be armed
with generative AI based solutions
that help them troubleshoot
problems in the field
faster and more accurately.
Another good example
is helping agents draft email
responses automatically,
based on the context or query,
allowing them to review and edit
before responding to the customer.
AI augmented emails
have shown to have a higher
satisfaction score by customers.
And the third area is in
contact center operations.
Let's say you have a
call center of a thousand
or maybe ten thousand agents.
Gaining insights into what's happening
across all the conversations
taking place between agents and customers
was difficult or expensive before.
With generative AI, you can
go through the transcripts
of every call made and
continuously gather insights
on how and why agents
are taking a long time
to handle certain types of calls,
or understanding granular
classification of complaints
on products or services.
This insight that a application
of generative AI provides
can allow your operations
leaders to find the root cause
of a problem faster and resolve them,
if in the servicing function,
or alert the product or marketing teams,
if they need to take remedial action.
There's also a lot of time spent by agents,
after each call with a customer,
documenting a summary
of their conversations
and actions taken.
During that after call work time,
they're unavailable to attend a new call.
Again, with generative AI,
you can transcribe in real time
the conversation that they're having
and generate a draft of the summary
that agents can then edit and
feed back into the CRM system.
Not only does this drive consistency
in capturing details of each
conversation with customers,
but it also saves time
and drives productivity
for the agents.
Today, as the cost of building
these solution comes down
with foundation models and
the ROI becomes justifiable,
there's a renewed focus
on the ways generative AI can
be used for customer service.
And it's not difficult to imagine why!
Customer service has always been complex.
Just think of the last time you called in
for customer service.
Chances are you wanted to
address a problem you were facing
with a purchase or a product
or a service you have;
and if you have a problem,
you are generally unhappy,
which is why enabling service
journeys that anticipate
and deliver delightful
omnichannel experiences,
whether as a self-service function
or a human assisted one is critical.
Secondly, in some companies,
there are a lot of employees
who can influence the
experience customers have
with the brand or service.
If you can augment their skills
and drive productivity
across this large population
who front your brand,
it'll be a huge win for your enterprise.
And given the capabilities of AI
and the rate at which it is evolving,
you can expect significant
gains in productivity
with the right deployment.
And there's more!
As businesses focus on building
omnichannel experiences
for their customers,
AI can power interactions
or conversations
irrespective of the channel
customers come in from.
Which means a customer request
that originated in one channel
can be completed in another
channel, seamlessly.
Combining traditional
AI with generative AI
enterprises can drive proactive outreach,
helping avoid problems or
help resolve them faster.
If you were to look closely
at how these companies achieve
high levels of coordination
amongst their channels,
you will discover a five step
approach driving the execution.
The first step, as you kick
off, is to have a clear idea
of the experience you want to deliver.
Next is to understand your customers well.
What is the demographic,
preferences, digital or voice?
And now that you know your
audience, you need to determine
how you want to serve them,
decide what channels you
want to direct them to.
And then, look at the best tools
that can support those channels.
So what is your platform?
Do you go with the cloud-based
contact center solution?
Will it be on-premises for
other reasons, or something else?
Once you have your tool chain sorted,
the final step is to design
the journey end-to-end,
so it delivers on the service strategy,
the experience you had
defined when you started.
My favorite story, and
it really warms my heart
whenever I speak of this,
is the work that we have been doing
with the US Veterans Affairs since 2019.
Before we came in, it used
to take a really long time
for veterans to get their benefits.
We applied analytics and automation
to help support faster claim creation
and response to veterans.
Just a few numbers: 3 million
packets processed end-to-end,
and these packets have
lots of documents in them.
280 different document types,
24 distinct mail type processes,
100% automation of all mail intake.
We are processing 220,000
documents per week.
We then took that process further,
by applying sophisticated AI
to analyze the medical records.
We are now helping the claims adjudicator
make decisions faster,
so that the veterans who
fought for our country
get the help they need
without the long wait.
And since 2023, we have
processed over 125,000 claims.
We have been expecting AI
to make a big difference
for quite some time now.
And I think the capabilities
have finally caught up with the hype.
What's more, the innovation
rate has also accelerated
dramatically, with a new
announcement almost every week.
It is becoming increasingly evident now
that the faster you add the capabilities
of generative AI to your organization,
the sooner you can make use
of the unlimited opportunities
it opens up.
Imagine the next time your
customer runs into a problem
and needs help: You'll
have all the capabilities
to turn a possibly adverse situation
into a positive experience,
without making them wait,
and perhaps, even before
they pick up the phone.
So the question for enterprises
looking to fold AI into
their customer service
is no longer, "Why?" But "When?"